con motivo de un 70 quinto día de la
independencia de la india el primer
ministro modi se dirigió a la nación
desde el histórico fuerte rojo mode y
empezó su discurso rindiendo homenaje a
los grandes de la lucha por la libertad
gandhi nehrú pero también agregó varios
nombres nuevos la nación está recordando
a aquellos que hicieron sacrificios pero
fueron olvidados dijo moody más adelante
modi se refirió a la india como el lugar
del nacimiento de la democracia nuestra
nación ha demostrado que tenemos la
fuerza inherente que proviene de nuestra
diversidad y el hilo común de
patriotismo que hace que india se
inquebrantable dijo moody también
resaltó la imagen de india como
autosuficiente una potencia
manufacturera del mundo mencionó que por
primera vez en 75 años las armas usados
por un saludo ceremonial fueron
fabricadas en india y el orgullo que
siente cuando los niños de hoy piden
juguetes hechos en la india y no de
países extranjeros el primer ministro
instó a los jóvenes a dedicar los
próximos 25 años de sus vidas al
desarrollo de la nación y que hicieran
cinco promesas crear un india
desarrollado quitar cualquier signo de
servilismo orgullo patrimonial unidad y
cumplimiento de nuestros deberes moody
también habló del daño del depotismo
diciendo que muchas instituciones han
sido dañadas por el gobierno familiar
comentando es nuestro esfuerzo que
aquellos que han robado el país tengan
que pagar en india donde la gente están
luchando contra la pobreza tenemos que
luchar contra la corrupción con todas
nuestras fuerzas